welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and zack snyder's justice league
has
a new trailer that's actually more or
less the same dc fandom trailer but
with a handful of new shots and an
accompanying live stream breakdown by
zack snyder himself given us a
ton of new easter eggs and layers of
meaning to this footage so we now have a
much fuller sense of what this four
episode hbo max mini series is gonna be
when it releases on the confirmed date
of
2021 hey we'll take it considering
another batman's got delayed to 20
hoodie what
snyder said that of the four hour long
episodes
two and a half hours of it will be new
never before seen footage and in the
past you've said that the rest of it how
all of it will only
be footage that he shot for his original
version of justice league so i'm gonna
break down all the new interesting stuff
that you might have missed now zack
snyder posted a black and white version
of the trailer
on his socials but we are gonna look at
the color version that came out
after and as i go i'm going to be
condensing and breaking down all the
major reveals from snyder's live stream
for you and uh yeah i am wearing a shirt
with my own name on it
but this is actually just one of many
fun designs that you can own yourself by
going to our official merch store
newrockstarsmerge.com
okay the trailer's opening shot shows
darkseid known here as his younger
self's name
ooxas whom snyder revealed was played
via motion capture by richard cetrone
ben affleck's batman stunt double he
does a lot of the mocap work in these
movies
uxs slams the earth with his staff which
snyder says was intended to reveal
the anti-life equation because uxis
thinks it's on earth
in that when this happens symbols will
form on the ground via lava that need to
be deciphered so the anti-life equation
is a kind of cosmic algorithm that
allows for the mind control of all
sentient beings in the universe
in jack kirby's comics darkseid targets
earth because he believes this equation
is embedded in the human subconscious
but here these lava symbols on the
ground will be how snyder visualizes
that equation
snyder confirmed that the shot of the
wayne manor ruins is filled with easter
eggs and cryptic messages
and what he calls pieces to the puzzle
many of which i did break down in the
last trailer so we know wayne manor was
being turned into the hall of justice at
the end of this movie and now in this
future aftermath there are easter eggs
pointing to each member of that team
there's
aquaman's three prong trident which is
interesting because that's the trident
of king atlan
not the five-pronged weapon that he
wields in this movie but the one that he
later receives at the end of aquaman
telling us that we are seeing a future
defeat of the justice league when they
are united in the future you can also
see diana's splintered
shield and a portrait of thomas wayne
bruce's father played by jeffrey dean
morgan
and then a joker card floats past
screaming not just any joker card this
is the same exact one that bruce had
taped onto
his gun in that nightmare sequence in
batman v
superman if you remember in that scene
bruce stepped up on the cliff from those
ruins
in the background so snyder is linking
all of this together and in terms of
cryptic messages it is fun to see what
snyder did here with the light
he singles out these justice league
easter eggs by reflecting sunlight off
of them
light glimmers off the shield and then
glimmers off the trident and then
through the s injustice as if to say
the house of l family crest translating
to hope that just happens to look like
an s
is really the justice league's hope to
preventing this apocalyptic future okay
next diana recovers the arrow of artemis
the one fired into the temple as a
warning upon steppenwolf's arrival now
snyder says that the
shaft of that arrow has clues that point
to the location of a true
hidden shrine to the amazons looking
closely at that aeroshaft it's kind of
hard to make anything out but again
follow the light here the shadow that
shaft makes on the
stone wall that shadow might point diana
to
a secret access point opening her up to
the real
inner shrine could be kind of an homage
to the staff of raw that indiana jones
uses to find the location of the ark
and we know from other footage that this
shrine will lead to the whole history
lesson that diana will witness
recounting the ancient war against uxus
snyder confirmed that this war takes
place chronologically before the
backstory we saw in wonder woman in
which ares betrayed the old gods now one
of the new shots of the trailer shows
diana and
arthur reacting to the hollow projection
of superman which schneider confirmed
was being projected from cyborg snyder
also said that this was happening not in
the batcave but
at a wayne aerospace hangar and that
here bruce is contemplating the
rebirth of superman what has to be done
snyder also said that in this hangar
bruce is working on
another vehicle beyond the flying fox
that we've seen
something for what he said was the war
to come
okay on the footage i'm honestly most
excited for victor stone's whole
backstory as a football player before he
becomes cyborg and his whole character
arc
it's something that was sadly just left
out of the theatrical cut gotham city
university is playing wisconsin notice
their helmets but apparently you could
see an
empty seat in the stands that should
have been filled by vick's father
silas stone who missed this critical
game because he was too busy working at
star
labs and then more new footage cyborg
watching kids play football in the
street outside their apartment where he
has been hiding ever since his accident
though vic is still in his gcu football
sweatsuit
snyder didn't spend too much time
talking about superman's emergence from
the scout ship
now wearing the black suit other than to
tease it will be an
epic moment but maybe it's because this
is a callback to his emergence from the
same portal of the scout ship that we
saw before
his first epic flight in man of steel
full circle baby by the way snyder also
confirmed that on that scout ship one of
these stasis bedpods was deliberately
left open in man of steel
intending to lead the door open to other
kryptonians existing
on earth all this time many believe it
to be kalil's cousin
cara zora l supergirl now in the shot of
diana greeting the schoolgirl snyder
confirmed that this girl is gonna ask
diana can i be like you one day and
diana's gonna answer with a resounding
yes i just hope that that little girl
isn't like that days today
and then takes day in his lasso of truth
and chokes a little boy with it tell the
truth
to be superheroes they should grow up to
be normal people who just act heroically
in their everyday life why does my mind
go to these places well before i
continue i want to thank our sponsor
honey
for helping us make this video honey
wants to help pay for one of your
holiday gifts this holiday season honey
is helping pay for
one million dollars worth of gifts as
part of the great honey gift away
thousands of prizes every week you know
honey as the free browser extension that
automatically searches for promo codes
when you're shopping
online but have you heard of honey's
other money saving tools like
drop list add things you want to buy to
your drop list at certain online stores
and honey will watch the prices
and let you know when the price drops on
your items so here's how the great honey
gift away works
add honey at joinhoney.com new rockstars
then
throw some gifts on your holiday drop
list for a chance to win
part of the 1 million dollars honey will
randomly select winners and give them
the money to help buy something on their
list
now i'm gonna add a few tabletop board
games to my holiday drop list
i see you gloomhaven and i'm coming for
you codename's duet
even if you don't win honey we'll let
you know if the price drops on anything
on your list so at least you can save
some cash pay less for your holiday
gifts have a chance to win
part of the one million dollar honey
gift way and support my channel by
supporting one of our biggest sponsors
get honey for free today at
joinhoney.comrockstars that's
rockstars okay on to the shots of barry
saving iris west
snyder says that this will be our first
introduction to barry's speed force and
his powers but that we won't see
how he got those powers barry here is
applying for a job at a pet store
but this scene will include details to
clarify the whole physics of barry's
powers
notice his shoes are burned off because
he moves so fast and that he is super
careful with iris because as snyder
points out if barry would have just like
carelessly moved people around as he
moved super fast he wouldn't tear their
freaking arms off so i think that
special little care that he gives iris
is what makes her respond that way
yes please but other than this snyder
said we won't be seeing much of iris in
this mini-series okay in the shot of
cyborg digging at the graveyard is
another easter egg that angel statue
snyder said this is the same statue he
put into his past films watchmen and
sucker punch
and then the shot of the five prong
trident comes from a new sequence with
arthur curry and volkow willem defoe's
mentor figure who gives arthur
the weapon of his mother atlanta snyder
explained that justice league used those
air bubbles for the atlanteans to talk
because if they were to try to talk
underwater their lungs and tracheas
would be filled with sea water
they're not holding their breath down
there they're just you know breathing
like fish do and that if it was all
clogged with water it wouldn't vibrate
their vocal cords the same way
like you know it kind of does if you
were going to swimming pool and talk
underwater that's all
air in there that's why you can still
produce the same sounds this is all to
explain why they did it their way versus
the way james one did an aquaman where
people just talked underwater i think
when we all saw that aquaman were like
yeah we don't need to overthink that
okay then another new shot with ooxisus
now
swapped into a previous version of the
shot that actually featured steppenwolf
behind him are the priests of the
motherbox
and they are forming the unity to reveal
the anti-life equation
which you can kind of see in the form of
energy from those lava symbols etched
into the earth flowing
up above ooxas and converging into what
will most likely be the mother boxes
but uxs is about to be foiled by the
protectors of earth which include the
united forces of the amazonians the
atlanteans the old gods most likely a
green lantern hanging out in there now
snyder explained
decide this guy is gonna be a liaison
between
darkseid and steppenwolf apparently he's
going to communicate via hologram then
there's a shot of cyborg reacting to his
father silas committing a selfless act
though
notice behind cyborg works steppenwolf
suggesting this is taking place right at
the last second
with steppenwolf nearly getting to the
mother box but silas is able to stop him
but i guess only in a way that fries his
own body
snyder acknowledged that that whole
visual is definitely a parallel to his
dr manhattan disintegration that he made
in watchmen
then another new shot in his trailer
hippolyta mid-fight
with the parademons you can see her
holding her mother box in her arm there
fending them off with a sword just to
keep it right out of reach
snyder also explained more about
steppenwolf's new design his
super spiky armor before the theatrical
cut
smoothed it down steppenwolf will strip
down from this armor at some point
but this new armor moves with him
emotionally kind of like its own
living breathing organism then there's a
shot of barry flashing over people's
heads according to snyder this is barry
zipping over their heads via the speed
force
protecting star labs employees from a
falling debris field you can actually
see
huge chunks falling down toward them but
then they disappear right as berry
silhouettes flash
up here and there to catch all these
different pieces then there's this shot
of batman catching parademon blasts on
his gauntlet
snyder revealed that alfred constructed
these new gauntlets and that there will
be a kind of debate between him and
diana over who was the real inspiration
for these kind of gauntlets implying
that batman must have borrowed diana's
tech after she saved his ass and batman
v superman thanks in part to her
gauntlets
one of the most interesting shots we
have seen shows barry in a kind of
psychedelic wind tunnel landscape which
schneider wouldn't confirm anymore about
other than to say that it is what we
think it is which is more or less him
confirming that we are seeing barry
sprint forward or backward in time here
maybe
tying up the loose scene from batman v
superman and or setting up the upcoming
flashpoint movie which is gonna deal
with timelines multiverses and time
travel now in the shots of the kent farm
snyder said that clark was interestingly
being
reborn into the memories of his life in
kansas
so this might be part of his
resurrection sequence and for the shot
of cyborg diverting the warhead snyder
said that this is vic
imagining what he's capable of now doing
with his technological
god mode that he can bypass digital
firewalls and networks and access all
military warheads
that must be if you look closely why his
anatomy is back to normal he's in his
gcu letterman jacket his hands and head
look normal this is his pre-accident
self that he's conceiving in his mind's
eye it's kind of cool that they're
depicting it this way the shot of cyborg
saving the cop in heroes park
is confirmed to be the role played by
mark mcclure jimmy olsen from the
superman films he's playing
officer ben sadowsky a more active role
than his brief brief cameo in the
theatrical cut with the flash
flying fox rises up to meet the justice
league and snyder confirmed that cyborg
is piloting it remotely
sorry to those of you who thought that
it might been martial manhunter at the
wheel there now according to snyder the
cut of all four parts
is locked meaning no new reassemblies
are gonna be necessary
and that he and his team are really just
tweaking the vfx in a lot of shots
so while hbo max continues to tease us
with a vague 2021 date
we could be looking at a release of this
of a very early 2021
and we are gonna be all over covering it
with breakdowns of every single one of
these so
be sure to subscribe to new rockstars
hit that notification bell for
everything that we're covering you can
also follow me on instagram at eavos
follow me rockstars thank you for
watching and a little update from
yesterday's reaction video despite my
best efforts to create a
copyright strike free video by not using
any of leonard cohen's alleluia
in that video it just kind of like
mutter singing it out of key
that singing was good enough to still
get a copyright strike
this freaking platform is insane then
this is why we really could use your
help by supporting us like buying our
merch and other things so if you want to
get on that
we'd appreciate it thanks for watching
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you